Alice had found herself in an
underground dreamworld where objects
talked and reality had been left behind
above-ground
Alice moved ahead knowing every moment
was a mixture of both reason and magic
away from reality space spins and time
expands what Alice didn't realize is
that when she had fallen down the rabbit
hole she had entered the subatomic realm
where particles can no longer be seen
and are placed scientific thinkers like
Schrodinger tried to peer into Alice's
sister had noticed she was missing but
was stuck in the ordinary world of
clocks and measuring sticks and would
never be able to find Alice the growing
edge of physics is to investigate not
only the world above ground but also the
underground world of Wonderland the
roots from which the trees and
experimental observations arise Alice's
next encounter was with two particles
Tweedledum and Tweedledee they were
identical and she had no chance of
telling them apart they were also very
energetic in fact Alice could work out
their energy given one clue that
Tweedledum and Tweedledee were electrons
a kind of subatomic particle called a
fermion fermions would fight too much if
they were stuck together so they can
never have exactly the same energy as
one another when one goes up the other
goes down if we wanted to map just one
particle we would write this
wavefunction but because we have to we
need to multiply this by itself the
negative sign ensures that when
Tweedledum and Tweedledee switch
positions nothing changes except that
they are in a different phase if there
was a plus sign instead we would be
dealing with bosons identical particles
that can have the same energy as one
another x1 and x2 are the positions of
each particle owl is the width of the
rabbit hole they are in a is a constant
which ensures the probability of finding
a particle doesn't go over 100% and in
importantly is the energy state of each
particle if we want to find the minimum
energy of Tweedledum and Tweedledee one
of them must have in equals 1 the ground
energy state but they can't both be 1 so
the other must be the next lowest in
equals 2
because we don't know which is one or
which is 2 we swap these around on each
side of the equation solving it would
give the probability of finding
Tweedledum and Tweedledee at a given
point the N values we have figured out
give their total energy which is the sum
of N squared times this constant K in
this case they will have an energy of 5
K enough to annoy Alice out of her mind